Dr Celine gallender is taking a stand
against different disinformation
following the death of her husband
Sports journalist Grant Wall he
collapsed last month while covering the
soccer World Cup in Qatar and was later
pronounced dead at a hospital Dr
gallender had a private autopsy
performed which found that wall died
from a ruptured blood vessel but many
have falsely blamed covid-19 vaccines
she writes about in a New York Times
op-ed titled Grant Wall was a loving
husband I will always protect his legacy
Dr Gander and Grant Wall were married
for 21 years she is also a CBS News
medical contributor good morning how are
you doing hanging in there good well
thank you for joining us we appreciate
you and we appreciate your transparency
um in this op-ed you call them
disinformation profiteers what do you
mean by that exactly well look there is
a business model for this these are
people who are trying to make money who
are trying to gain social media
followers or sub stack newsletters
subscribers who are looking for either
social status and power and they are
using stories like that of my husband to
profit off of that I am so saddened
Celine hurt and angry that you even feel
that you have the need to do this that
people actually came for you and were
and were accusing saying horrible things
about what they wanted to do to you
falsely claiming that he died because of
covid were you surprised that even you
were attacked and he was attacked this
way I really was well I've been attacked
for years now um in the work that I do
as an infectious disease specialist
epidemiologist as somebody who is very
pro-vaccine because we know they're
highly effective and safe they save
lives it's one of the most important
things that medicine actually has to
offer to save lives so that they would
come for me not necessarily but that
they would come for my husband
that really made me angry and under the
circumstances was also really hurtful I
just wanted to take a breath and grieve
with my family and I'm not being allowed
to do that by these folks yeah and let's
talk about grant for a second because he
was healthy so what happened to him was
just a fluky kind of thing wasn't it he
was healthy he was a healthy man
completely healthy this is a guy who
worked out with a trainer a couple times
a week would go on the rowing machine a
couple times a week a very very healthy
guy but at the same time he had an
underlying genetic risk factor we were
not aware of there was no reason for us
to test for it until that point which
we've now uncovered during his autopsy
but I think what you're seeing is this
pattern of vaccine Skeptics who are
saying oh look at these young healthy
people it must be coveted vaccines and
that is simply not the case you write
that after Grant's death you swallowed
your grief while protecting his legacy
and trying to end these rumors and you
say that medical information can
re-traumatize families are you prepared
to be re-traumatized by writing this
op-ed because you know they were coming
after you before probably going to come
after you again oh I'm sure they will
and I've already gotten a handful of
those kinds of messages I will say the
vast majority of the Outreach that I've
gotten since the op-ed has been very
positive and supportive but look you
know for me it's really important that
his legacy be protected that he not get
pulled into this anti-vaxxer mess and I
will do whatever I need to do to protect
his memory how do you want him to be
remembered
I want him to be remembered as the kind
generous person that he was he was so
generous to anybody from a student to a
young reporter who was coming up in
sports sports journalism and he used
sports journalism as a tool to advance
social justice whether that was for
women and soccer and basketball or for
LGBT rights during his memorial I just
saw the outpouring of love from people
not just beautiful journalists but it
was incredibly beautiful and moving and
you could just feel the love for four
grand all the lives that he touched yeah
amazing we're so glad you're here please
know we're always cheering you on and
always here to support you have a lot of
support out there thank you Celine thank
you for coming and I know this is tough
we'll be right back